Hi there, Shankar here. This week we are bringing you an episode from the archives. Maybe more than any other hidden brain episode, this one brings a smile to our faces. And right now, that's something we can all use. Here it is. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantum. When Sophie Scott was about six, she came across her parents doing something very strange. They were rolling around, laughing. In my memory, they were actually on the floor of the living room, absolutely overcome with laughter.
大家好，我是尚卡尔。本周我们为您带来一期来自资料库的节目。也许比任何其他《隐藏的大脑》节目都要多，这期节目能让我们会心一笑。而现在，这正是我们所有人都能用得上的。节目开始。《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。索菲·斯科特大约六岁的时候，偶然撞见父母在做一件非常奇怪的事。他们在地上打滚，大笑。在我的记忆里，他们其实就躺在起居室的地板上，笑得完全不能自已。
They'd laughed so much they could literally do nothing else but laugh. What had got them laughing was a song. A comedy song about what people were not supposed to do in toilets on trains. It's said to be quite a famous piece of music and it's going to be customers. Well, please refrain from passing more to while the train. We encourage constipation while the train is in the station. And as they remembered more and more of it, they got more and more helpless. Now maybe you're thinking, wait, this song isn't that funny. But we've all been there, right? You're with a friend, they say something ridiculous, and then your laughter triggers their laughter.
他们笑得太厉害了，除了笑什么也做不了。让他们发笑的是一首歌。一首关于人们不应该在火车的厕所里做什么的喜剧歌曲。据说这是一首相当著名的乐曲，即将为顾客播放。好吧，请在列车行驶期间克制自己，不要再排泄了。我们鼓励在列车进站时便秘。随着他们记起越来越多的歌词，他们越发无能为力。现在也许你在想，等等，这首歌没那么好笑。但我们都有过这种经历，对吧？你和朋友在一起，他们说了句荒谬的话，然后你的笑声引发了他们的笑声。
Sophie didn't know then that laughter would play a big role in her life, but today she thinks about laughter a lot. She's a neuroscientist who studies the science of laughter. So she often thinks back to that moment with her parents back when she was six. Years and years later my father was mortally ill. I mean he thought he was dying, we all thought he was dying. And the doctors didn't know what to do. And it was all we were just sitting around waiting for something to happen. And my father suddenly said, we've laughed
索菲当时并不知道笑声会在她的一生中扮演重要角色，但今天她经常思考笑声。她是一名研究笑声科学的神经科学家。因此，她经常回想起当年她六岁时与父母在一起的那一刻。很多很多年以后，我父亲病危。我的意思是，他以为自己快要死了，我们都以为他快要死了。医生们也不知道该怎么办。我们只是坐在那里，等待着事情发生。我父亲突然说，我们笑得够多了，不是吗？我说，是的，我们笑过很多。我当时想，你知道，这算什么奇怪的话？直到多年后，当我做了更多关于笑声的研究时。我想，不，他是对的。你知道，如果你能回首一生，发现自己曾与周围的人、与你关心的人一起开怀大笑过，那些时光并非虚度。
a lot, haven't we? And I said, yes, we have. And I thought, you know, what's strange thing to say? And it was years later when I was doing a lot more work on laughter. I thought, no, he was right. You know, if you can look back on a life where you've shared a lot of laughter with the people around you, with the people that you care about, those are not times wasted.
那些是美好的时光，是真正重要的时光，去让自己珍视这一点，而不是认为这是愚蠢或微不足道的、浪费所有人时间的行为，你应该把时间花在严肃的事情上。你知道，笑声是值得被认真对待的。今天，我们认真对待笑声。索菲·斯科特向我们讲述了笑声的丰富色调。从礼貌的…………到尴尬的……
Those are the good times, those are the times that really matter and letting yourself value that rather than thinking that it's a silly or trivial waste of everyone's time, you should be spending your time being serious. You know, it's worth taking the laughter seriously. Today, we take laughter seriously. Sophie Skar tells us about the varied shades of laughter. From politeness... ...to discomfort...
哦！……到愉悦的。解码笑声的含义…………本周《隐藏的大脑》。索菲·斯科特是伦敦大学学院的神经科学家。她研究笑声、大脑如何处理笑声，以及笑声在塑造社会连接中所起的作用。索菲，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨。索菲，我想放给你听一段非常奇怪的声音剪辑。我碰不到你。我以前从未听过这个。我假设那是某人在笑，也许不是。
Oh! ...to delight. Decoding the meaning of laughter... ...this week on Hidden Brain. Sophie Scott is a neuroscientist at University College London. She studies laughter, how laughter is processed by the brain, and the role it plays in shaping social connection. Sophie, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi. I want to play you a clip of a very strange sound, Sophie. I can't touch you. I've never heard that before. I'm assuming that is someone laughing, maybe not.
关于笑声的关键在于，它更像是动物的叫声，而不像是人类的任何语言。因此，它在人类和其他动物之间可以非常相似。这正是我想要探讨的。这是一段某人不可遏制地大笑了的音频剪辑，但听起来好像有另一个生物接管了这个人的身体。你知道，所有的修饰和文化教养都抛到了九霄云外，你听到了这些奇怪的声音，几乎是动物般的叫声。
And the point's about laughter is it's more like an animal call than it is like any human speech. So it can be extremely similar between humans and other animals. That's what I wanted to get to. This is a clip of someone laughing uncontrollably, but it's almost as if another creature has taken this person over. You know, all the polish and the culture have gone out the window and you get these strange sounds, it's almost animalistic sounds.
确实如此，事实上，在我们日常的正常行为中，人类对自己的行为和发出的声音有着极大的控制力，而这其实正是人类与众不同的地方之一。我们不仅能对环境做出灵活的反应，还能调节我们的反应方式。许多其他动物，特别是发声方面，它们的叫声具有高度的反射性，发生了某事它们就会发出声音，某种触发因素引发了声音，它们就会发出声音。
It really is, and we actually, in our normal day-to-day behaviour, humans have a lot of control over the things that we do and the sounds that we make, and actually that's one of the things that's unusual about humans. We don't just react flexibly to our environment, but we can modulate how we respond. A lot of other animals, particularly for vocalizations, their vocalizations are highly reflexive, something happens and they make the sound, something triggers the sound, they make the sound.
而我们只有少数几种声音是来自这种更偏向反射性、非自主性的途径。当它们从你体内迸发出来时，可能会相当吓人。比如哭泣、咕哝和惊讶的倒吸气等声音。几个星期前，我在做电台录音，出乎意料的是我们在一个化学实验室里，结果发生了一次爆炸。不管怎样，让我们直接开进去看看吧。
And we have a handful of sounds that we make that are from this more kind of reflexive, involuntary route. And it can be quite startling when they come out of you. Sounds like weeping, grunting, and gasp of surprise. A few weeks ago, I was doing a radio recording and unexpectedly we were in a chemistry lab, but there was an explosion. Anyway, let's just drive it in and see.
而在磁带里，我发出了一个非常标准的、表示惊讶的“哦”的声音。哦。那是一个非自主的发音，对吧。我不知道你有没有注意到。我本来并不希望发出叫声。因为我其实有点吓到了。我想，噢，真烦人。
And on tape, I made a proper kind of surprised, oh, sound. Oh. That was an involuntary vocalization, then. I don't know if you noticed. I was not hoping to make cries. Because I was actually a little bit startled. And I thought, oh, that's really irritating.
我居然发出那种声音了。但那是完全不由自主的。大笑也可以是这样的。它会让人感觉像是从我们体内喷涌而出。当我们那样大笑时，发出的声音可能在一切条件相同的情况下，我们其实并不想发出来。它可能会变得极其……嗯，非常动物性。
I haven't done that. But it was completely involuntary. And love to can be like that as well. It can just feel like it's issuing forth from us. And we can make sounds when we're laughing like that that probably all other things being equal. We probably prefer not to make. It can be extremely, well, very animal.
而且它确实是动物性的。它以完全相同的方式将我们与其他动物发出的声音联系起来。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，损……索菲问，声音呢？我之所以对笑声产生兴趣，是因为我对非语言发声感兴趣。比如我惊讶时发出的“哦”，或者在恐惧中尖叫。我一直在研究这些，因为我们对人类如何识别情绪感兴趣，而几乎所有这方面的研究都是通过面部照片完成的，这延续了像保罗·艾克曼这样的人的出色工作。
And it is animal. It's linking us exactly the same way that other animals make sounds. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Sophie asked, what about sounds? I got into love to by being interested in non-verbal vocalization. So something like me going, oh, when I'm surprised, or screaming in terror. And I was working with those because we were interested in how humans recognize emotions and pretty much all the work on that is done with photographs of faces, following in the beautiful work of people like Paul Eckman.
而我正试图找出这些面部表情的听觉发声版本。所以我尽量避开情感语言，因为面部表情没有任何言语内容。正是通过观察这些，然后开始观察不同种类的表达——可能既有积极的情绪，也有像恐惧和愤怒这样的消极情绪——这实际上引导我走向了笑声。所以我从未一开始就立志研究笑声。我对这些非语言声音很感兴趣，它们可能是高度非自主的，事实上，当我们发出这些声音时，它们更像是动物的叫声而不是语言。我们并没有做任何说话时对嘴唇、下巴、牙齿和舌头所做的那些复杂细致的动作。
And I was trying to come up with auditory vocal versions of those. So I was trying to steer away from emotional speech because the faces didn't have any verbal content to them. And it was looking at those and then starting to look at different kinds of expressions that may be more positive emotions as well as negative emotions like fear and anger is what actually led me to laughter. So I never set out to study laughter. I was interested in these non-verbal sounds and they can be highly involuntary and in fact when we make them they are much more like animal cause than they are like speech. We don't do any of the fancy detailed movements of the lips and the jaw and the teeth and the tongue that we do when we're talking.
事实上，我们的嘴往往什么动作都不做。你可能会做一个面部表情，然后你只是从声带里把气挤出来。笑声 有没有证据表明其他动物会像人类一样笑？有证据表明其他动物会笑，所以其实很容易在其他类人猿身上看到这一点。事实上，查尔斯·达尔文对此写了相当多的文章。类人猿的笑声与人类的非常非常相似，嗯，我们就是类人猿，你知道的。
We in fact often the mouth doesn't do much at all. You might pull a facial expression and then you just squeeze air out through the voice books. LAUGHTER Is there evidence that other animals laugh, like humans laugh? There is evidence that other animals laugh, so it's actually very easy to see it in other apes. In fact, Charles Darwin wrote quite a lot about this. Ape laughter is very, very similar to human, well we're apes, you know.
非人灵长类动物的笑声与人类的笑声非常相似。所以如果你听到一只黑猩猩在笑，那看起来真的很像笑。所以你看，它在视觉上与人类的笑声非常非常相似。但也有一些笑声，类似于在其他非类人猿动物身上被描述过的发音，它们在进化层面上距离我们稍微更远一些。所以笑声已经被……嗯，类似于笑的行为已经被已故神经科学家潘克谢普描述过，他当时在研究大鼠。他注意到老鼠在彼此玩耍时会发出一种非常独特的发音，
A non-human ape laughter is very similar to human laughter. So if you were to hear a chimp laughing, it looks really like laughter. So you see, it's very, very visibly similar to human laughter. But there is also laughter, like vocalizations that have been described in other animals that aren't apes and are sort of somewhat further removed from us in evolutionary terms. So laughter has been, well laughter like behaviour has been described by Pankskept that the Lake Neuroscientist and he was working with rats. And he noticed that rats make a very distinct vocalization when they're playing with each other,
他们想知道这是否类似于笑声，因为在类人猿中，笑声与玩耍有着强烈的联系。于是他们开始给老鼠挠痒痒，这也是你在类人猿身上发现笑声的时候，老鼠在被挠痒痒时也会发出同样的声音。他们真的把老鼠关在笼子里，然后探身去给它们挠痒痒吗？是的，是的，如果你……他们发现这是非常重要的事情，所以老鼠在玩耍和被挠痒痒时确实会发出这种发音。如果它们希望你给它们挠痒痒，它们就会发出这个声音。如果它们看到你走进实验室，而你通常会给它们挠痒痒，它们就会发出这种声音。顺便说一句，这些声音音调太高，通常人耳是听不到的。
and they wondered if that was something like laughter, because laughter is strongly associated with play in apes. And so they started tickling the rats, which is when you also find laughter in apes, and the rats make the same sound when they're tickled. They actually got rats in a cage and leaned in and tickled them, literally? Yes, yes, and if you, what they find is that really important stuff, so rats definitely produce this vocalization when they're playing and when they're being tickled. And if they want you to tickle them, they will make the sound. And if they see you come into the lab and you normally tickle them, they make the sounds. These sounds, by the way, are so high-pitched, they normally can't be heard by the human ear.
你必须对录音进行处理，才能听到老鼠对挠痒痒的反应。所以这确实似乎是对玩耍的一种邀请，潘克谢普称之为邀请，但它可能不仅仅是一件微不足道的事。他发现，你对一只幼鼠挠痒痒越多，当它是幼鼠时，这只老鼠作为成年鼠被挠痒痒时就会笑得越多，所以你可以增强笑声，老鼠告诉我们是这样的。最近一些关于老鼠笑声的研究表明，如果你切断老鼠的声带或发声器官，它们就无法发出任何声音。如果你让这些老鼠打闹，
You have to manipulate the recording to hear how rats respond to tickling. So it really does seem to be a kind of an invitation to players, PankScap called it, but it may not just be a trivial thing. He found that the more you tickle a baby rat, when it's a baby, the more that rat will laugh when it's tickled as an adult, so you can potentiate laughter, the rats tell us. And some more recent work with laughter and rats is shown that if you remove the vocal chords of the voice box from rats, they can't make any vocal sounds. If you let those rats scrap and get it, they'll
与其他老鼠互动，与其他老鼠玩耍，但如果它们和另一只老鼠玩耍，它们更有可能被咬。因为当老鼠一起玩耍时，笑声发出的其中一个作用是，它表明“我们还在玩”，这有助于你管理这种互动，因为玩耍时发生的相同行为可能会蔓延成攻击行为，而如果它们不会笑，来自老鼠的数据实际上表明这会让你很难进行管理。我想放给你们听另一个片段，它展示了无法控制的笑声以及它是多么奇怪。这是一个我认为
interact with other rats, they'll play with other rats, but they are more likely to be bitten if they play with another rat. Because one of the things that the laughter vocalisation is doing when the rats play with each other is it's signifying we're still playing and it helps you manage that interaction because the same behavior that happens during play could just spill over into aggression and if you can't laugh the data suggests from the rats actually that's hard of you to manage. I want to play you one more clip that shows uncontrollable laughter and how strange it is. It's a clip that I
你很熟悉的片段，索菲，两个BBC评论员在谈论一场板球比赛。我打算播放这个片段的一个稍微延长版本，因为听听它是如何发展的很值得。他完全知道接下来会发生什么。他直接跨过三柱门，用右手轻轻弹了一下截木横木。你试过劈叉，理查德。不幸的是，他侧腹的内侧刚才一定碰掉了横木。他没能把腿迈过去。无论如何，他表现得非常出色，大约131分钟，击出了三个四分球。
think you're familiar with, Sophie, two BBC commentators are talking about a cricket game. And I'm going to play the clip at a slightly extended version of the clip because it's worth hearing how this develops. It's new exactly what's going to happen. It's right to step over the stumps and just flick to bail with his right hand. You've tried to do the splits, Richard. unfortunately, the inner part of his side must have just removed the bail. He just didn't quite go his leg over. Anyway, he did very well indeed, about 131 minutes and hit three falls.
然后我们有路易斯表现极佳，但他的47分未出局。阿加斯，住手。劳伦斯总是那么有趣，如果打出35分的话。35分钟，在弱势球员头上打出一个4分。我当时想这是一条蛇僵尸。那是劳伦斯。表现不错。这是一个4分，打在弱势球员的头上。这其实是一个艰难的球。所以索菲，这些是实况广播中的专业广播员。听起来几乎像是某种东西接管了他们。所以BBC非常明确地对新闻广播员和体育广播员感到生气，
And then we had Louis play extremely well, but his 47 not out. Agas do stop it. Lawrence always entertaining, bad if a 35. 35 minutes, hit a 4 over the week he was. I was thinking this is a snake zombie. There's Lauren's. See me well. It's a four, I'm the weak human's head. He was actually a tough one. So Sophie, these are professional broadcasters on live radio. It's almost as if something has taken over. So the BBC very specifically gets cross with particularly news broadcasters and sports
那些在BBC广播电台做直播的人，BBC不喜欢他们大笑或表现出情绪，他们称之为“破功”，而且他们知道自己要惹麻烦了。他们真的不想，你知道，当时的情况是他们不想笑。但当它缠上你时，它就会发生。笑声能够压倒我们运动神经系统的方式有一种令人难以置信的强大力量。所以它让我们停止呼吸。它让我们停止说话。
broadcasters, people who are doing things live on BBC Radio, the BBC does not like them to laugh or show emotion, they call it breaking, and they knew they were going to get in trouble. They really didn't want to, you know, the situation is they don't want to be laughing. But when it's got, it's clause in you, it will happen. There's something unbelievably powerful about the way laughter can overwhelm our motor system. So it stops us breathing. It stops us talking.
你听到他们完全无法继续说话，而他们唯一要做的就是在电台里说话，这是他们谋生的手段。他们在笑，笑声阻止了他们做所有这些事情，它就那么袭来了，基本上你只能硬挺过去。就在快结束的时候，你听到了布赖恩·约翰逊的声音，有时候你根本说不出话来，有时候你会说，你击中了一个四分，我必须保持镇定，因为他正试图在笑声中继续说话。这是一件非常非常强大的事情，实际上会让人无法说话。这太不可思议了。你知道，你说的有两件事让我印象深刻。一个是，你知道，
You heard they were completely unable to keep speaking and all they have to do is talk on the radio, it's what they do for a living. And they're laughing, stopping them doing all that in, it just comes along and basically you have to just power through it. And right towards the end, you heard Brian Johnson's voice, you get a time you can't talk at all, other times you're going, you hit a four, I have to keep a set because he's trying to talk through the laughter. That's a very, very powerful thing to happen, actually render someone unable to speak. It's extraordinary. You know, there's two things that you said that jumped out at me. One is that, you know,
这其中很大一部分是社交性的。换句话说，其中一个评论员在告诉另一个请停下来，因为如果你不停下来，我就停不下来。我也有过这种经历，当你笑得无法控制时，你对旁边的人说，你需要停下来，因为如果你不停下来，我就完全失控了。所以这是一个有趣的观点。但第二个有趣的观点是，为什么进化会在我们体内创造出这样一种机制，从根本上切断我们呼吸的能力？这非常有趣。所以，如果你回到关于社交和传染的观点，在某种程度上，这可以说是行为传染的一个纯粹例子，因为他们两个都只是因为对方在笑而笑。有趣的是，如果他们互不相识，
so much of this was social. In other words, one of the commentators is telling the other one, please stop because if you don't stop, then I can't stop. And I've had that experience too, where you're laughing uncontrollably and you're telling the person next to you, you need to stop because if you don't stop, I don't have any control. So that's one interesting point. But the second interesting point is, why would evolution create something in us that would essentially cut us off from being able to breathe? It's very interesting. So if you're going back to your point about the social and the contagion, so that in some ways that is a pure example of behavioral contagion because they're both only laughing because the other one is laughing. Interestingly, if they didn't know each other,
他们以这种方式分享笑声的可能性就会小得多，因为你不会像从你认识的人、也许是你喜欢的人那里传染笑声那样，去从一个你不认识或不喜欢的人那里传染笑声。所以我认为这是另一个原因，因为BBC现在喜欢播放那个片段。我想这也是另一个原因，因为BBC现在喜欢播放那个片段。我想那是因为25年前我们知道，如果那两个人互相憎恨，他们就不会那样笑了。你知道我的意思吗？
they'd be much less likely to share laughter that way because you don't catch laughter from someone you don't know or don't like in the same way as you catch from someone you know and maybe someone you like. So I think that's the other reason because the BBC likes playing that clip now. And I think that's because other reason, because the BBC likes playing that clip now. And I think that's because we know 25 years later that if those two men had hated each other, they would not have been laughing that way. Do you know what I mean?
在那里你实际上听到了一些真实的东西。那是对彼此陪伴的完全未经修饰的喜悦，它压倒了一切。你知道，我以前有个朋友前段时间去美国访问，这位朋友不会说英语，但她当时在听一个公共广播电台播出的节目，叫做《汽车谈话》。你好，欢迎收听国家公共电台的《汽车谈话》，与我们一起的是点击和克拉克兄弟。
You're hearing something real actually there. That's a completely unmoderated joy in each other's company that is overruling everything else. You know, I had a friend who visited the United States some time ago and this friend didn't speak English, but she was listening to a program that used to run on public radio called Car Talk. Hello and welcome to Car Talk from National Public Radio with us clicking on the tap at brothers.
这两个人基本上是在谈论汽车修理，但实际上谈论的是他们之间的关系，节目中会有很长的一段，基本上是两人陷入歇斯底里的狂笑。史蒂夫，我给你找到了一辆车。我准备好了。一辆埃尔卡米诺。他们就是无法停止嘲笑对方和他们自己，而我那个不会说英语的朋友非常喜欢这个节目。是的，你甚至会注意到，当你对一个沃尔沃车主说，哦，这要一千块钱，他们会说，哦，只要这个。只要这个。
They essentially had these two guys talking about car repair, but really it was about the relationship between them and they would be these extended sections of the show where the two of them essentially would be in hysterical laughter. I have the car for you Steve. I'm ready. An El Camino. They just could not stop laughing at each other and at themselves and my friend who did not speak English loved the show. Yeah, you even noticed when you said to a Volvo owner, oh, it's going to be a thousand bucks, they say, oh, only that. Only that.
因为她说，听这两个人笑——那种失控的笑声——有一种魔力，能让她感到快乐。笑声所传达的某种语言，甚至可能超越了语言本身。确实如此，我认为部分原因在于，正如你的朋友所经历的那样，它是一种普遍的情绪。所以无论你走到世界的哪个角落，你都会遇到笑声，而它的核心都有着相同的含义。
Because she said there's something about listening to these two people laugh, you know, out of control laughter, that made her happy. There's something that language that laughter communicates that even perhaps goes beyond language. It does, and I think part of it is because, you know, as your friend is experiencing, it is a universal emotion. So wherever you go in the world, you'll encounter laughter, and it has at its heart the same meaning.
它是非常真实的，它在向你传递非常积极的信息，而遇到这样的事情总是令人愉快的。接下来，是什么让我们开怀大笑？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。事情通常是这样的。你在家里办公，然后通过电话会议拨入早上的会议。欢迎，请输入您的访问码。大家都在桌旁愉快地聊天。但当你静音坐在那里时，这一切听起来一点都不好笑。你简直不敢相信大家看起来玩得那么开心。在聊一些毫无意义的事情。
It's very truthful, and it's telling you something very positive, and that's always a sort of wonderful thing to encounter. Coming up, what makes us laugh? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Here's how it usually goes. You're working from home and you call in by conference call for the morning meeting. Welcome, please enter your access. Everyone is happily chatting around the table. But as you sit there on mute, it all sounds very unfunny. You can't believe how much fun people seem to be having. Talking about nothing.
然后有人开始笑。很快所有人都笑了。除了你，默默地听着电话，你甚至连一丝微笑都没有，更别提笑了。你在想，这段对话是什么时候变得这么搞笑的？我错过了什么？嗯，事实证明，笑声往往与对幽默的反应无关。这是基于罗伯特·普罗文对笑声研究成果的一个见解。这位是神经科学家索菲·斯科特。我曾以为幽默是驱动笑声的主要因素。
Then someone starts to laugh. Soon everyone's laughing. Except for you, silently listening on the phone, you're not even cracking a smile, forget about laughing. You wonder, when did this conversation become so hilarious? What am I missing? Well, it turns out laughter often isn't about responding to humor. It's an insight based on the work of laughter research of Robert Provin. Here's neuroscientist Sophie Scott. I thought that humor was the main thing that drove laughter.
当我最初研究笑声时，我就是这么称呼它的。我称之为愉悦感。我想，哦，这是愉悦感的一种表达。然后我读了罗伯特·普罗文的著作。罗伯特·普罗文非常明确地指出。尽管我们认为我们是对幽默和笑话发笑，但我们的标签、我们的心理——这也是我曾经认同的——认为这是一种对幽默的反应。我们发出的大多数笑声
That's what I called laughter for years when I was first working with it. I called it amusement. I thought, oh, it's an expression of amusement. And then I read Robert Provin's work. And Robert Provin is very clear. Although we think we laugh at humor and jokes, our label, our psychology, which I shared, is that it's a reaction to humor. Most of the laughter
其起源纯粹是社交性的。我们在与其他人在一起时会笑，相比于独处，当我们和他人在一起时，我们更容易被触发笑声。其他社交因素，比如我们是否认识这些人，我们是否喜欢这些人，也会融入其中。我听说早期的研究发现，在几乎80%到90%的情况下，你知道，笑声都紧随诸如“回头见”或“很高兴认识你”这样完全不好笑的话语之后。完全正确。这是因为我们笑，我们笑是为了展示什么，我们笑是为了建立和维护社交纽带。我的意思是，笑声可以成为一种非常有效的方式，用来缓和与某人的社交互动。
that we produce is purely social in its origins. We laugh on where with other people, we're primed to laugh when we're with other people more than if we're on our own. And other social factors like, do we know those people, do we like those people that will feed into that? I understand some of the earlier research found that almost 80, 90% of the time, you know, laughter followed phrases like, you know, I'll see you later or it was nice meeting you at things that were completely unfunny. Exactly. And it's because we laugh, we laugh to show what we laugh to make and maintain social bonds. I mean, laughter can be a really efficient way of just smoothing over a social interaction with somebody
但当我们与那些我们进行着更持久对话的人在一起时，那种笑声同样也带有展示赞同、展示理解、展示认可的意味。你知道，就是在说“继续说，是的，我想我记得这个，但请继续告诉我”。你知道，它包含所有这种细微的含义。普罗文甚至发现，在任何给定的时间点，对话中笑得最多的人其实是正在说话的那个人，这确实表明它被用作
But when we're with people that we're having a more enduring conversation with That laughter is as much to do with a showing agreement showing understanding showing recognition You know saying go on. Yes. I think I remember this but carry on telling me you know It's got all this kind of nuanced meaning and Provin's even found that at any point in time, the person who laughs most in a conversation is the person who's talking, which really does suggest that it's being used
一种极具交际性的方式。所以我想谈谈笑声的社会属性以及笑声音轨的背景。在某种程度上，这是媒体劫持我们大脑中笑声运作方式的一个例子。我想放给你一段电视剧《宋飞正传》的剪辑。你在干什么？
in a very communicative way. So I want to talk about the social nature of laughter and the context of laugh track. So this is an example of the media in some ways hijacking the way laughter operates in our brains. I want to play you a clip from the TV show Seinfeld. What are you doing?
什么？难道……你刚刚把那个薯片二次蘸酱了吗？对不起？你把薯片二次蘸酱了！二次蘸酱，你在说什么呢？你把薯片蘸了酱。你咬了一口，然后又蘸了一次。笑声
What? Didn't... Did you just double-dip that chip? Excuse me? You double-dip the chip! Double-dip what are you talking about? You dipped the chip. You took a bite, and you dipped again. LAUGHTER
那么，笑声音轨告诉了我们关于笑声社会属性的什么信息呢，索菲？嗯，关于笑声音轨有趣的故事是，当我们开始能够录制和广播我们希望人们觉得好笑的节目时，它们成了一种必需品，因为笑声的天然家园是在社交场合以及戏剧和表演环境中，人们会在那里笑——他们会在剧院里笑，他们会在音乐剧里笑，他们会在看别人表演时笑，但这总是一种共享的体验，你身处观众之中，是一群欢笑的人的一部分。而一旦你转向一个
So what do laugh tracks tell us about the social nature of laughter, Sophie? Well, the interesting story of laugh tracks is that they became a necessity when we started to be able to record and broadcast programs that we were hoping people would find funny because the natural home of laughter is in social settings and in theatrical and performance environments people would be laughing they'd laugh at the theatre they'd laugh at musical they'd laugh at people doing performance stuff, but that was always be a shared experience you were in an audience and you were part of a group of people laughing and as soon as you go down to A shared experience, you were in an audience and you were part of a group of people laughing and as soon as you go down to something that's being broadcast, people don't necessarily
共享的体验，你身处观众之中，是一群欢笑的人的一部分。而一旦你转向某种正在播出的内容，人们不一定能
get all those cues. So suddenly they were finding that people weren't necessarily hearing a radio program or sounding funny because there were no cues to help you hear that. So a solution to this problem of people, that's not necessarily finding things funny if there wasn't the sound of laughter but also studio laughter, sometimes being hard to control. Charles Douglas, who was a sound engineer invented, a sort of a laugh box where he had recordings of laughter, which he could mix together and drop in, and then this became very easily controlled because you then have this technique for being able to have exactly as much laughter as you want at the time that you want it without having to worry about the empty silences or uncontrollable studio laughter.
接收到所有这些线索。所以突然之间，他们发现人们不一定觉得广播节目听起来很好笑，因为没有任何线索能帮听出这一点。因此，为了解决人们不一定觉得事情好笑（如果没有笑声的话）的问题——而且演播室的笑声有时也很难控制——查尔斯·道格拉斯，一位音响工程师，发明了一种类似笑声盒的装置，里面存有笑声录音，他可以把这些录音混合在一起并插入节目中，然后这就变得非常容易控制了，因为你随后就拥有了这样一种技术：能够在你想让观众笑的时候，恰好提供你想要的笑声分量，而不必担心出现尴尬的沉默或无法控制的演播室笑声。
And it's kind of incredible isn't it, which is in some ways the studio is manipulating when you laugh, not with the jokes but with the laugh machine. I suppose in a sense they always were. It is interesting that if you look at... because some programs carried on making a point saying, you know, this is filmed in front of a live studio audience. So, Seinfeld is an example of cheers, friends, they would make it quite a big deal that you knew this thing was being performed in front of an audience. And in fact, friends would, they would do a whole rehearsal with a live audience there and look at when people laughed and go away and reworked lines so you could maximize the relationships and what was being said and when the laughter happened. So they were almost being scientists about it, which is
这真是有点不可思议，不是吗？某种程度上，是演播室在操控你什么时候笑，不是靠笑话，而是靠笑声机器。我想从某种意义上说，他们一直都在这么做。有趣的是，如果你看看……因为有些节目坚持强调，“你知道，这是在现场演播室观众面前拍摄的”。所以，《宋飞正传》就是一个例子，《欢乐酒店》、《老友记》都会大肆宣传，让你知道这东西是在观众面前表演的。事实上，《老友记》会带着现场观众进行完整的彩排，观察人们什么时候笑，然后回去重新加工台词，这样就能最大限度地强化人物关系、台词内容以及笑声发生的时间。所以他们几乎是以科学的态度对待这件事，这可以说是
a manipulative. It's all trying to control the audience laughter because it's considered to be something that makes it sound better. And I think one of the things that's interesting about studio laughter or candl laughter, as people started calling the, you know, an extra recording that's been dropped in, is that one of them started to be very, considered to be very infred, you know, not quite the thing. So we, we came a bit snobbish about Candle After. In the UK, I think, Mash was famously shown without Candle After in the US.
一种操纵。这都是为了控制观众的笑声，因为它被认为能让节目听起来更好。我认为关于演播室笑声或罐头笑声（人们开始这样称呼那种被强行插入的额外录音）有趣的一点是，其中一种开始被认为是非常俗气的，你知道，有点上不得台面。所以我们对罐头笑声有点势利眼了。在英国，我认为，美国的情景喜剧《陆军野战医院》著名的一点就是播出时没有罐头笑声。
It was. I need my things. Oh, yeah. I packed your toothbrush with jammies and one of your slingshots. You jerk face. That's my garter belt. It has quite a different experience watching the two. I need my things.
确实如此。我需要我的东西。哦，对的，我把你的牙刷和睡衣还有你的弹弓打包了。你这个混蛋，那是我的吊袜带。观看这两者的体验完全不同。我需要我的东西。
Oh yeah, I packed your toothbrush with jammies and one of your slingshots. You jerk face, that's my garter belt. It sort of became a bit of a cultural thing about whether or not you had laughter on it at all so it became more of a fashion for comedy to not need that. So things like the office in the UK didn't have a laughter track of any kind and would have looked down a little bit.
哦，对的，我把你的牙刷和睡衣还有你的弹弓打包了。你这个混蛋，那是我的吊袜带。这在某种程度上变成了一种文化现象，即节目中到底应不应该有笑声，因此喜剧不需要笑声成了一种更流行的趋势。所以像英国版的《办公室》就没有使用任何形式的笑声轨，并且可能会对
I suspect on programs that felt they needed to. So, you know, it's definitely, it's not just the laughter and whether the laughter is live or canned. It's to do with your view of the sort of programs that might need laughter or do you think they need laughter. You know, are understanding of laugh tracks
那些觉得自己需要笑声轨的节目略带鄙视。所以，你知道，这绝对不仅仅是关于笑声本身，以及笑声是现场的还是罐头笑声。它与你对可能需要笑声的节目的看法有关，或者你是否认为它们需要笑声。你知道，我们对笑声音轨的理解
gets a bit nuanced. You said a second ago that people can be snobbish about laugh tracks, but people are also in some way snobbish about laughter. We think of one kind of laughter as real and one kind of laughter as fake. So the social greeting laughter we think of as fake and we think about the rolling on the floor helpless with laughter as real. It is social laughter fake and spontaneous laughter real? Well, at one level they are, and you know, it's the case that the spontaneous laughter,
变得有些微妙。你刚才说人们对笑声音轨会有势利眼，但人们在某种程度上对笑声本身也带有势利眼。我们认为某一种笑声是真实的，另一种笑声是虚假的。所以我们认为社交问候的笑声是虚假的，而那种笑得在前仰后合、不能自已的笑是真实的。社交笑声真的是虚假的，而自发笑声是真实的吗？嗯，从某种层面来说，它们确实是，你知道，事实确实如此，自发的笑声——
the kind of stuff you cannot stop doing, is definitely different to laughter that at some level is a performative or a communicative element. And I must admit, sometimes I call them real and fake laughter just because it's very easy and people know what I mean but I'm very well aware that when you call it fake you're you are valencing it you're making it sound like it's a bad thing and of course most of the time the vast majority of time it's not a bad thing at all it's a great thing. You recognize the meaning of laughter that a friend gives you or someone gives you it has a positive aspect to it and the fact that somebody's giving you their laughter,
那种你无法停止的笑——与在某种层面上具有表演性或交际性成分的笑绝对是不同的。我必须承认，有时我称它们为真实和虚假的笑，只是因为这样非常简单，人们也知道我在说什么，但我非常清楚，当你称之为“虚假”时，你其实是在给它赋予价值判断，你把它说得好像是一件坏事，而当然，大多数时候，绝大多数时候，这根本不是一件坏事，而是一件极好的事情。你识别出朋友给你的笑声或某人给你的笑声的含义，它具有积极的方面，而且事实上有人把他们的笑声送给你，
the fact that they're actually choosing to produce that laughter for you, we've found that people actually seem to be marking the communicative laughter. For example, in the UK, it can quite often be very nasal, that sounds to it. You couldn't do that if you were laughing spontaneously, and that really does suggest that people are going out of their way to say, look, I'm giving this to you. This is laughter I'm trying to produce for you. In an interaction where you like the person, you have a good relationship with that person, you know what that means and you take it. I think the situation is where we get upset
事实上他们实际上选择为你制造那种笑声，我们发现人们实际上似乎在标记交际性的笑声。例如，在英国，它通常会带有非常明显的鼻音。如果你是在自发地大笑，你是做不到这一点的，这确实表明人们在刻意地表达：“看，我这是在送给你。这是我试图为你制造的笑声。”在一段你喜欢对方、与对方关系良好的互动中，你明白这意味着什么并且接受它。我认为我们感到不安的情况是
by laughter that sounds put on is when we don't know those people. You've ever been on a train with a load of friends who all seem to be sitting there and they're like, ha ha ha ha. And you're like, oh, goodness me, they're all faking that laughter. Because if you're one of the friends, you wouldn't care at all. You know, because you're not part of that group, you are isolated from it and you're hearing the performance of this rather than the warmth. And also if you're, I've tried this isn't science, but if you think about it, there's
对于听起来很做作的笑声，通常发生在我们不了解那些人的时候。你有没有坐过一列火车，车上有满车的朋友，他们好像都坐在那里，然后发出“哈哈哈哈”的笑声。然后你会想，天哪，他们全是在假笑。因为如果你是那些朋友中的一员，你根本就不会在意。你知道，因为你不是那个群体的一部分，你被孤立在外，你听到的是这种表演而不是温暖。而且如果你是……我试过这个，这不是科学，但如果你仔细想想，有
some of you know who laughs really inappropriately who hasn't it retating laugh. If you think about that, most people think of someone and I've never found anyone who really likes that person. So actually, so I have a relative who's always, I've always thought, oh, they laugh really inappropriately. And so working with the laughter is I've realized it's because there's nothing inappropriate about their laughter. I don't join in with it because I don't really like them. And it's me with holding my laughter that I'm
你认识的某个人，他笑得非常不得体，而且有一种让人恼火的笑声。如果你想想看，大多数人都会想到这样一个人，而我从来没有遇到过真正喜欢那样一个人的人。所以实际上，我有一个亲戚，我一直认为，哦，他们笑得太不得体了。所以通过研究笑声，我意识到这是因为他们的笑声其实没有什么不得体的地方。我不跟着一起笑，是因为我其实并不喜欢他们。是我在克制自己的笑意，而我却把这体验为
experiencing is them doing something wrong. And they're laughter being irritating but it's not it's me that's being different. So that's an interesting insight because what you're saying is that it's your affection or lack of affection that prompts you to see that that laughter is being inappropriate or appropriate or enjoyable. So it's really we think in the conventional way we think someone has an inappropriate laugh, I don't like it, but really you don't like them and that's why you think the laugh is inappropriate. I think so and I think actually I'm this is actually, I mean this is a hypothesis, let's be generous. I don't have any data to back this up, but I think we do that quite a lot with laughter,
他们在做错事。并且觉得他们的笑声很烦人，但事实并非如此，是我自己在表现得与众不同。所以这是一个有趣的见解，因为你所说的是，正是你的喜爱或缺乏喜爱，促使你认为那种笑声是不合时宜的、合时宜的还是令人愉快的。所以实际上，我们按照传统思维认为某人的笑声不得体、我不喜欢，但实际上是你本就不喜欢他们，这才是你觉得那个笑声不得体的原因。我想是的，而且我认为实际上——这是一个假设，让我们慷慨一点。我没有任何数据来支持这一点，但我认为我们在笑声中经常这样做，
because we do the opposite as well. If somebody makes us laugh, we will say, oh, they're hilarious, they're gonna great sense of human, they make us laugh. What they mean is, I really like them. I really like them when I laugh and I'm around them, so that they will know that I like them, and maybe they'll like me too.
因为我们也会做相反的事情。如果某人让我们发笑，我们会说，哦，他们太搞笑了，他们真有幽默感，他们让我们发笑。他们的意思是，我真的很喜欢他们。当我笑的时候我真的很喜欢他们，而且我和他们在一起，这样他们就会知道我喜欢他们，也许他们也会喜欢我。
You know, it's a, it's a, it's a, but we attribute it to other people. We attribute our laughter to other people or our lack of laughter. We attribute to other people. Laughter in other words can tell us a lot about relationships between people. It's a signaling device. But how are we so good at decoding what laughter means? Sophie had a hunch. She conducted an experiment to show that the brain actually processes different kinds of laughter differently.
你知道，这是一个……但我们把这归咎于其他人。我们把自己的笑声归咎于他人，或者把我们缺乏笑声归咎于他人。换句话说，笑声可以告诉我们很多关于人与人之间关系的信息。它是一个信号传输出。但是我们为什么能如此擅长解码笑声的含义呢？索菲有一个直觉。她进行了一项实验，表明大脑实际上对不同类型的笑声有不同的处理方式。
She recruited a couple of people to join her on her London campus. She invited them into a strange little hut. Inside this hut was a windowless room, where all the surfaces were covered with wedges of foam, and the only things in the room were a pair of speakers, a chair, and a computer monitor that was bolted to the wall. Once the door was closed, you could finally encounter true silence and experience few people could tolerate for more than a few minutes. Inside this tiny,
她招募了几个人来到她在伦敦的校园。她把他们请进了一个奇怪的小木屋里。这个小木屋里面是一个没有窗户的房间，所有的表面都贴满了泡沫楔块，房间里唯一的东西是一对扬声器、一把椅子和一个固定在墙上的电脑显示器。一旦门关上，你终于能体验到真正的寂静，这种体验很少有人能忍受超过几分钟。在这个极其微小、
joyless chamber, Sophie recorded herself and the two other people laughing. It is a weird little spice because it's perfect for making absolutely beautiful recordings, but it's sort of antithetical to getting people laughing. She used a few tricks. She started slow. We spent a long time warming them up before we tried to put anyone in the Anacote Chamber and on their own to laugh. And then we'd make sure that the person in the Anacot chain,
了无生气的房间里，索菲录下了她自己和其他两个人的笑声。这是一个诡异的小空间，因为它非常适合录制绝对完美的音频，但它又有点与让人们开怀大笑的初衷背道而驰。她用了一些小技巧。她从慢热开始。我们在试图让任何人进入消音室并让他们独自大笑之前，花了很长时间为他们热身。然后我们会确保消音室里的人
but when they did, you know, when they were laughing, we kind of throw them in their closer door and start recording. Once she had her beautiful recordings of different kinds of laughter, she played these clips for volunteers as the lay inside a brain scanning machine. Her question, would the brain register the difference between laughter that was polite and laughter that was spontaneous. And what we find is people hear laughter and they start trying to work out what it means.
但是当他们开始笑的时候，你知道，当他们在笑的时候，我们就把他们关在里面，关上门开始录音。一旦她获得了各种不同笑声的高品质录音，她就把这些音频片段播放给躺在脑扫描仪里的志愿者听。她的问题是：大脑会记录下礼貌的笑声与自发的大笑之间的区别吗？我们发现，人们听到笑声时，会开始试图弄清楚它的含义。
And if the laughter is spontaneous, you get a different pattern of neural activation and if the laughter is some level being intentionally produced. And in fact that is reflected in the brain activation you see. When the volunteers heard uncontrolled belly laughs, the brain scans showed they focused on the sound of the laughter. But when they heard the recordings of the polite chuckles, the brain scans suggested the volunteers were thinking. They were asking the question, what's really going on here? For Sophie, the experiment confirmed that laughter always means something. It's a
如果笑声是自发的，你就会得到一种不同模式的神经激活，而如果笑声在某种程度上是刻意制造的。事实上，这反映在你所看到的脑部激活中。当志愿者听到无法控制的开怀大笑时，脑部扫描显示他们专注于笑声的声音。但当他们听到礼貌的轻笑录音时，脑部扫描表明志愿者们在思考。他们在问这样一个问题：这里到底发生了什么？对索菲来说，这个实验证实了笑声总是有含义的。它是一种
cold, we're always trying to decipher. This might be why most of us can tell the difference between laughter among friends and laughter amongst strangers. It turns out you don't need to know anything about the two people laughing. You don't even need to see them. All you need to do is hear them laugh for one second. Some years ago, the cognitive scientist Greg Bryant at UCLA recorded pairs of friends and pairs of strangers having a conversation. He pulled out all the moments when they laughed and then cut the laughter into tiny bursts
总是在试图破译。这或许就是为什么我们大多数人都能分辨出朋友之间的笑声和陌生人之间的笑声。事实证明，你根本不需要了解这两个笑的人。甚至都不需要看到他们。你只需要听他们笑上一秒钟。几年前，加州大学洛杉矶分校的认知科学家格雷格·布莱恩特（Greg Bryant）录下了多组朋友和陌生人交谈的音频。他提取了他们所有的笑声片段，然后把笑声剪切成极短的碎片，
that lasted just a second. He and his colleagues played these tiny little laughter clips for nearly a thousand people from 24 societies all over the world. The researchers asked the volunteers if they could tell whether the people laughing were friends or strangers. Why don't you see if you can tell the difference? Here's one set of three laughs strung together. And here's another.
持续时间仅仅只有一秒钟。他和同事将这些微小的笑声片段播放给来自全球24个不同社会的近一千人听。研究人员询问志愿者，他们能否分辨出笑的人是朋友还是陌生人。你为什么不也来试试看能不能分辨出来呢？这是一组连在一起的三声笑。这是另一组。
And here's another. If you guessed that the first clip was strangers and the second clip was friends, you're right. Most people in the study got it right. People all over the world could hear the difference. And it makes sense because we don't laugh with just anybody. You know, laughter is a very good index of how we feel about the people that we're with. And it's not like we're laughing or we're not laughing and that's the only difference. You can have much more kind of performative, you know, if I bump into someone in the street, we both laugh and say, we're okay, I'm not going to stand again. That laughter wasn't very intense because I know what it means.
还有这一组。如果你猜第一段音频是陌生人，第二段是朋友，那你就猜对了。研究中的大多数人确实都猜对了。世界各地的人都能听出其中的差别。这其实很好理解，因为我们不会随便跟什么人都笑。你知道，笑声是衡量我们对身边人感受的一个很好的指标。这并不是说我们要么在笑、要么没笑，这唯一的区别。笑也可以带有更多的表演性质，你知道，如果我在街上撞到某个人，我们都会笑笑然后说，我们都没事，我不会再挡道了。那种笑并不是那么强烈，因为我知道它意味着什么。
You know, it was doing its job of sorting out a slightly difficult situation. Whereas with a friend, the laughter is likely to be much warmer because it needs to be, and it can be, and it's an index actually of how those friends feel about each other. So, I think it's interesting that we're so alive to it, like we really notice it. And as I say, I think that's because it's incredibly important, the social signal, and we recognise its emotional meaning. your signal and we recognize this emotional meaning. This emotional meaning is usually positive but not always. When we come back the connection between laughter and power. A quick note before we start this next segment.
你知道，它起到了化解略微尴尬局面的作用。而面对朋友时，笑声往往会温暖得多，因为这不仅必要，而且可能，它实际上正是这些朋友彼此间真实感受的写照。所以，我认为有趣的是，我们对这种情感如此敏感，我们真的能注意到它。正如我所说，我认为这是因为这种社交信号极其重要，我们能识别出它背后的情感含义。你的信号，我们能识别出这种情感含义。这种情感含义通常是积极的，但也不总是如此。广告之后，我们将探讨笑声与权力的关系。进入下一段之前，先做个简短的说明。
It includes a discussion of sexual assault. During the 2018 Supreme Court confirmation hearing for then-judge Brett Kavanaugh, there was a moment when the role of laughter took center stage. California psychologist Christine Blasiford had accused Kavanaugh of sexually assaulting her when they were both teenagers in Maryland. She said that Kavanaugh had leaped on top of her and tried to disrupt her at a party while a friend watched. Kavanaugh strenasonously denied the allegations.
其中将包含关于性侵犯的讨论。在2018年时任法官布雷特·卡瓦诺（Brett Kavanaugh）的最高法院提名听证会上，曾有一个时刻，笑声的角色成为了全场的焦点。加州心理学家克里斯蒂娜·布拉西·福特（Christine Blasey Ford）指控卡瓦诺在马里兰州两人都是青少年时曾对她进行性侵。她表示，卡瓦诺曾扑到她身上，并试图在一次聚会上捂住她的嘴，而旁边有一个朋友在围观。卡瓦诺极力否认了这些指控。
The US Senate invited Christine Blassey Ford to testify and Senate something that you cannot forget. Take whatever time you need. Indellable in the hippocampus is the laughter, the the aperious laughter between the two, and they're having fun at my expense. You've never forgotten that laughter. You've never forgotten that laughter. You've never forgotten them laughing at you. They were laughing with each other. And you were the object of the laughter?
美国参议院邀请克里斯蒂娜·布拉西·福特作证，参议院……有些事情你是无法忘记的。请花去你需要的任何时间。深深烙印在海马体中的是那种笑，他们两人之间那种放肆的笑，他们拿我寻开心。你永远不会忘记那种笑。你永远不会忘记那种笑。你永远不会忘记他们嘲笑你。他们当时在互相取笑。而你成了被嘲笑的对象？
I was, you know, underneath one of them, while the two laughed. Two friends having a really good time with one another. Sophie, I don't want you to get into the debate of a Kavanaugh, but as a researcher who studies laughter, how do you respond to what Christine Ford told the Senate? Well, it's almost unbearable to listen to, but it's also very recognizable because if you think about laughter as being about making and maintaining social bonds, it has to mean by definition that someone is excluded from that bond. Otherwise, it doesn't mean anything. So we normally dwell on the positive side of that look. We're making and maintaining
是的，你知道的，我被压在其中一个人身下，而他们两个却在一旁大笑。两个朋友在一起玩得非常开心。苏菲，我不想让你陷入关于卡瓦诺的辩论中，但作为一个研究笑声的研究人员，你如何看待克里斯蒂娜·福特对参议院所说的话？嗯，听这些简直让人难以承受，但同时也让人觉得非常熟悉，因为如果你认为笑是为了建立和维持社会纽带，那么根据定义，这就必然意味着有人被排除在这个纽带之外。否则，这就没有任何意义。所以我们通常只关注那种积极的一面，看吧，我们在建立和维持
social bonds and that's great. But if you are excluded from that, you're excluded from that laughter, it's awful. And you're awful because we have a very, very strong understanding of what that means. And there's a lot more to this, there's the situation where something terribly serious is happening from your perspective, something awfully serious is happening, that is being treated as fun by other people. There was a court case in the UK recently where a woman's son had been murdered. And in the court, the two young men who were up for his murder were laughing and joking. And she made a statement precisely about this. They can't even take this seriously.
社会纽带，这太棒了。但如果你被排斥在外，被排除在那种笑声之外，那就太糟糕了。你会觉得糟糕，因为我们对于这意味着什么有着非常非常深刻的理解。这里面还有更多内容，比如从你的角度来看，正发生着极其严重的事情，某种糟糕透顶的严重事情，却被其他人当成了一场游戏。英国最近就有一个法庭案件，一个女人的儿子被谋杀了。在法庭上，那两个因涉嫌谋杀他而受审的年轻男子却在一边笑一边开玩笑。她专门就此发表了一份声明。他们甚至无法严肃对待这件事。
My son's death and they're going to go to prison for it and they are still laughing. And I can totally understand one that was almost the worst part of what was going on for her. That's like marking how little they care about your situation. So it can be very powerful. That kind of distinction, who is laughing at who, who is got a bound with who and who's being excluded from that can be a very, very marked way of not just excluding somebody from a social group, but actually marking them as inferior. And we have this behavior that's being done done by the people who are more important, the people who have greater status, they can find something fun and enjoyable because they're the ones with the power.
我儿子的死，而他们却将因此入狱，结果他们居然还在笑。我完全能够理解，这几乎是她所经历的事情中最糟糕的一部分。这就好像是在强调他们有多么不在乎你的处境。所以这可以产生非常强大的力量。那种区别——谁在笑谁，谁和谁是一伙的，谁又被排斥在外——可以成为一种非常非常鲜明的标志，不仅能把某人排斥在一个社会群体之外，实际上还能把他们标定为低人一等。而这种行为是由那些更重要的人、那些拥有更高地位的人做出来的，他们能从中发现乐趣和享受，因为他们是掌握权力的人。
And in some ways laughter is a way to reinforce statuses, isn't it? I mean, I'm thinking about schools, for example, when you think about bullying in schools, one of the things that happens is that a group of kids is laughing at another kid, the kid who is isolated is, recognizes, the experience of being isolated partly by who is laughing at him or her. Absolutely. So again, the same laughter can be incredibly warm, positive, friendly doing all its work for the people within the social group and then be absolutely awful to the person social group and then be absolutely awful to the person who's being not only excluded from it but is the target for the laughter. And it's one of the worst sensations, you know, if you realise not only are people laughing and they're not, you're nothing to do with
从某种意义上说，笑声是巩固社会地位的一种方式，对吗？我的意思是，我想到了学校，例如，当你想到学校里的霸凌时，发生的其中一件事就是一群孩子在嘲笑另一个孩子，那个被孤立的孩子，他会意识到，这种被孤立的体验部分来自于谁在嘲笑他或她。完全正确。所以再次证明，同样的笑声可以极其温暖、积极、友好，为社会群体内部的人发挥着所有的积极作用，但对那个不仅被排斥在外、而且成为笑声靶子的人来说，却可以绝对糟糕透顶。这是最糟糕的感觉之一，你知道，如果你意识到人们不仅在笑，而且这与你毫无关系，
it but actually no, hang on, they're laughing and they're laughing at you. It's just sickening, it's a horrible feeling because it's one of the most basic things we care about as humans. We're social primates who we get to hang out with, who talks to us, who's what social network we're part of. That really matters. And when you get this absolutely clear example, not only are you excluded from this group, but they would care so little to have you be part of them, that they would mark you out as being worthy being laughed at. It's almost, it's extraordinary. You can see the power of laughter to bond and the power of laughter to exclude in one of the most famous clips in the news from the last few years.
但实际上不，等等，他们不仅在笑，而且是在嘲笑你。这简直让人反胃，这是一种可怕的感觉，因为这是作为人类我们在意的最基础的事情之一。我们是社会性灵长类动物，我们和谁一起闲逛，谁跟我们说话，我们属于哪个社交网络。这真的非常重要。当你遇到这种绝对清晰的例子时，你不仅被这个群体排斥在外，而且他们根本不在乎让你成为他们的一部分，以至于他们把你标定为活该被嘲笑的对象。这简直太不可思议了。你可以从近年来新闻中最著名的片段之一中，看到笑声凝聚群体和排斥异己的力量。
In 2005, Celebrity TV host Donald Trump was on his way to film an episode of Access Hollywood. He was having a casual conversation with Billy Bush, a younger man known for his easy rapport with celebrities. Trump was talking about the woman he was about to meet. Yeah, that's it. With a gold, I'm going to use some text just in case you start kissing her. Pay attention here to the role that laughter plays in their exchange. You know, I'm automatically attracted to beautiful. I just start kissing them.
2005年，名人电视主持人唐纳德·特朗普在去拍摄一集《好莱坞内幕》（Access Hollywood）的路上。他当时正和比利·布什（Billy Bush）随意交谈，比利是一个以善于和名人打成一片而闻名的年轻人。特朗普正在谈论他马上要见到的那个女人。没错，就是她。带着金发，我要用点手段以防你开始亲吻她。这里请注意笑声在他们对话中扮演的角色。你知道的，我对美女有一种天然的吸引力。我直接就开始亲吻她们。
It's like a magnet. Just, I don't even know where. And when you're a star, they let you do it. You can do anything. Whatever you want. Grab them but. BEEP. You can do anything.
就像磁铁一样。甚至不知道在哪里。当你是个明星时，她们就会让你这么做。你可以为所欲为。无论你想做什么。抓住她们的……哔。你可以为所欲为。
Sophie Scott argues that powerful people often use laughter as a way to cover up misdeeds and indiscretions. When they are called out on their behavior, they say they are joking, that it was just locker room talks. Yes, the Donald is good. Oh my man! Wait, wait, you got to look at me. Because we aren't very good at understanding that most of our life is nothing to do with humour. We can mistake the fact that people who are laughing in a situation with us aren't laughing
苏菲·斯科特认为，有权势的人经常利用笑声来掩盖不当行为和轻率举动。当他们的行为受到质疑时，他们会说自己只是在开玩笑，这不过是更衣室的闲聊。是的，唐纳德真厉害。哦，我的老兄！等等，等等，你得看着我。因为我们不太擅长理解我们生活中绝大多数事情其实都与幽默无关。我们会误解这样一种事实：那些在某种情境下和我们一起笑的人，其实并不是因为
because what we said was funny, they're laughing because they like us and they're part of the same group as us. But if you go away from that, you know, if you were to choose to take from that, oh, I'm hilarious, then you could also choose to use that as your defense for somebody else objecting to what was going on there. And it's a very, very common one. Often I think when people say, or, you know, it was just locker room chats, it was, I was being funny, what they mean is, you know, I almost don't need to justify myself to you. But I think also it can be, it can kind of conflate difficult in a difficult way with this notion of power because it is the case that if you look at strongly hierarchical situations, I think there was work with doctors in the UK with a senior doctor will have a very different social status than the junior doctors in his or her group and there was data showing that the junior doctors would laugh at something the senior doctor said and
我们说的话很好笑才笑，他们笑是因为他们喜欢我们，而且和我们属于同一个群体。但如果你脱离了这一点，你知道，如果你从中得出结论说：“哦，我太搞笑啦”，那么你也可以选择以此作为借口，来为别人反对你当时的行为进行辩护。这是一种非常非常普遍的现象。通常我认为，当人们说，“哦，你知道的，那只是更衣室闲聊，我只是在搞笑”时，他们的意思是，“你知道的，我几乎不需要向你解释自己。”但我也认为，这可能以一种困难的方式将这种情况与权力概念混为一谈，因为事实确实如此，如果你看看高度等级化的情境，我想英国曾有针对医生的研究表明，资深医生的社会地位与他或她组里的初级医生截然不同，有数据表明，初级医生会对资深医生说的话发笑，而
the senior doctor would very, very rarely laugh at something the junior doctor said. Now that's normally taken to mean that people find the stuff funnier if it's produced by the senior person. I think it's also, as likely, that the junior people are trying to make themselves liked by the senior person by giving them the laughter. You know, it's something we will actively try and use around people. But it does mean that bosses who might have got used to people laughing at what they say and are not realising it's because of who they are, rather than what they're saying,
资深医生却极少对初级医生说的话笑。现在，这通常被理解为人们觉得由位高权重者说出的话更有趣。但我认为，同样有可能是初级医生试图通过讨好资深医生、给他们奉上笑声来博得他们的喜爱。你知道的，这是我们会积极尝试在人们周围使用的一种手段。但这确实意味着，那些可能已经习惯了别人对自己说的话发笑、却没意识到这其实是因为他们的身份而非他们所说的话的老板们，
may find themselves in a situation where they have said something genuinely offensive. And when they get called on it, they can't, you know, they were all just, it was just banter, just being hilarious, but what they were simply something genuinely offensive and when they get called on it, they can't, you know, they were all those, just, it was just banter, I was just being hilarious, but they were simply straight up offensive. Lafter can also be used by the weak to hold a powerful to account. Historians talk about the role of the court jester, often the only one who could speak truth to power, usually through a laugh. Even in countries with authoritarian regimes, laughter can be a sly way to undermine leaders
可能会发现自己陷入了这样一种境地：他们说了一些真正具有攻击性的言论。而当他们因此受到质问时，他们却无法，你知道的，他们就会说，大家只是闹着玩，这只是玩笑，只是觉得好笑而已，但他们实际上就是直接发出了具有攻击性的言论。笑声也可以被弱者用来追究权者的责任。历史学家们谈到过宫廷小丑的角色，他们通常是唯一敢于对权势说出真话的人，而且通常是通过笑声来实现的。甚至在拥有威权体制的国家里，笑声也可以成为一种暗中破坏领导人
and register discontent. I asked Sophie if laughter could be the weapon of the week. It can just be a straightforward weapon, so to be clear, it doesn't only have to be used by the week, but it can work very well. So laughter can be a very good way or rather than just getting angry about somebody, pointing out enormous shortcomings
和表达不满的狡黠方式。我问苏菲，笑声是否能成为弱者的武器。它完全可以成为一种直接的武器，需要明确的是，它不一定只能被弱者使用，但它确实能发挥很好的作用。所以笑声可以是一种极好的方式，比起对某人气急败坏，它能指出对方在言论或行为上的
in their statements or their behavior, in a way that creates people laugh. Sort of, it goes your signalling kind of playful intent and they're also clearly mocking them. You were excluding them and laughing at them. Sometimes there was a UK Prime Minister, John Major, who never really recovered from some journalist spotting when they were on the campaign trail with him, that he tucked his shirt into his underpants. You could sort of see it through his, you know, you got very close to him. And they just became
巨大缺陷，并且是以一种能逗得大家发笑的方式。某种程度上，这传递了你的戏谑意图，同时又显然是在嘲弄他们。你是在排斥他们并嘲笑他们。有时候，英国前首相约翰·梅杰（John Major）就曾遭遇过这样的困境，当时他在进行竞选活动时，被记者们发现他把衬衫下摆塞进了内裤里，他再也无法从中恢复过来。你甚至可以透过他的衣服看到这一点，你知道的，记者离他非常近。而他们只是
relentless. Now, by no means, his worst was the prime minister, as a political person, but it was like the thread that was easily pulled out and everything kind of fell from there. It was absolutely relentless and how that was run with. Laughter can also be used to hold other people at a distance. In our current politics, both liberals and conservatives love to mock each other. It's a way of not having to listen to people you disagree with. Laughter becomes a weapon to solidify the distaste that each tribe has for the other.
紧追不舍，毫不留情。现在，就政治人物而言，这绝不是首相最糟糕的地方，但这就好比一根很容易被抽出来的线，随之而这一切都瓦解了。这种穷追不舍以及他们借此大做文章的方式绝对是冷酷无情的。笑声也可以用来与他人保持距离。在我们当前的政治环境中，自由派和保守派都喜欢互相嘲弄。这是一种不用去倾听与自己意见相左的人讲话的方式。笑声成了巩固每个群体对彼此厌恶情绪的武器。
The elite! Why are they elite? I have a much better apartment than they do. I'm smarter than they are. I'm smarter than they are. I'm richer than they are. Because it turns out the name Trump was not always his family's name. One biographer found that oppressive ancestor had changed it from, and this is true, DRUNP. Yes! It's grouping writ large. You know, these big social groups, you can sort of see it in the UK around Brexit with both sides trying to paint the other is ridiculous
精英！为什么他们是精英？我的公寓比他们好得多。我比他们更聪明。我比他们更聪明。我比他们更有钱。因为事实证明，“特朗普”这个名字并不总是他家族的名字。一位传记作家发现，他的一位压迫性的祖先曾把姓氏改过，千真万确，改成了“德鲁普”（DRUNP）。是的！这就是群聚现象的放大版。你知道的，这些大型社会群体，你可以在英国脱欧时期的两派身上看到这种现象，双方都试图把对方描绘成荒谬可笑的形象，
and to better or less, you know, success. Be funny about it. Um, you're using it to mark the commonality with the group of people you share something with as well as your difference from and sort of separation from and the ridiculousness of that other group. We've talked a lot about your research and your ideas, but I understand that for the past a few years you've also been a stand up comedian yourself. Do you remember how you felt the first time you got a really big laugh?
而且取得了或多或少的成功。拿这个开玩笑吧。嗯，你用它来标榜你所认同的群体之间的共同点，同时也借此凸显你与另一个群体的差异、隔阂以及那个群体的荒谬性。我们已经聊了很多关于你的研究和想法，但我听说在过去的几年里，你自己也成了一名单口喜剧演员。你还记得第一次听到全场爆发出巨大笑声时的感受吗？
I can tell you how I felt before then, I don't think I've ever been so nervous. Not since my exam at when I was at school, I'm literally at one point locked myself in the toilet, thought I could just stay in here, you know, I don't have to come out ever. And the first time I got a laugh, and it wasn't a laugh I was expecting, it wasn't on a line, I wasn't on a line that I thought was funny, I thought, oh, it's all, you know, you know, I can see light at the end of the tunnel, you know, I'm gonna be able to get through this. But the bit I really remember,
我可以告诉你那时候之前的感受，我想我从来没有那么紧张过。自从上学时的考试以来再也没有过，我甚至有一刻把自己锁在洗手间里，心想我可以直接待在这里，你知道的，我永远都不用出去了。而当我第一次逗笑大家时，那并不是我预料中的笑声，那不是在一个梗上，那不是在我认为好笑的包袱上，我想，哦，这一切，你知道的，你知道的，我看到隧道尽头的光了，你知道的，我能挺过这一关了。但我真正记住的片段是，
so when you finish the, you know, stand up normally in the UK, there's an MC who comes on and claps the nut, you know, and the guy came, I left the station, this guy came out and went, ladies and gentlemen, so big! And everyone was clapping and I was like, yes! Okay! Okay! this guy came out and went, ladies and gentlemen, so big! And everyone's clapping and I was like, yes! So big!
所以当你完成，你知道的，在英国做完单口相声表演后，通常会有一个主持人上台来鼓掌，你知道的，然后那个人上台了，我离开了舞台，这家伙走出来说：“女士们先生们，太棒了！”每个人都在鼓掌，当时我就想：太棒了！好吧！好吧！这家伙走出来说：“女士们先生们，太棒了！”每个人都在鼓掌，当时我就想：太棒了！
People can carry on doing this for as long as they wish to. This is pure hits of dopamine to my nucleus of coverage, you know. Perfect. And then really my next coherent thought was, I want to do that again and I want to do it better. I want to learn how to do this. It's very hard to say this without sounding like you, I don't know, the undead, but I like brains.
人们可以一直这样持续下去，只要他们愿意。这简直是对我伏隔核的纯粹多巴胺冲击，你知道的。完美。然后我的下一个清晰的念头是：我还想再来一次，而且我要做得更好。我想学会怎么做这件事。很难在不听起来像个僵尸的情况下说出这句话，但我喜欢大脑。
And I work with brains. And I'm very lucky because I get to use a technique called Mae'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gweithio'r gweithio, mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
而且我研究大脑。我很幸运，因为我能够使用一种叫做……的技术。
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith was anything other than that. Well, what I try and do is I take real science
……除了那个之外别无其他。好吧，我尝试做的是，我汲取真实的科学知识，
and I take stories, things that have happened to me or my family and I try and turn that into a short, informative, but hilarious set. But what I quite often do is actually take examples of things that have been upsetting. So I once got picked on by some teenage boys at Ips, which were our way station. And it was horrible and they were all laughing at me.
并结合各种故事——发生在我自己或我家人的事情，然后我试着把这些转化成简短、信息丰富但又妙趣横生的段落。但我经常做的一件事，其实是取材于那些令人沮丧的经历。所以我有一次在伊普斯（Ips）被几个十几岁的男孩子欺负过，那是个中途停留站。那感觉太糟糕了，他们都在嘲笑我。
And it was really nasty. It was really, really unpleasant. And I turn that into a stand-up act. a'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffyni'r ffynio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn These fear sciences. They'll be laughing on the other side of their faces. Thank you very much. Sophie Scott is a neuroscientist at University College London, where she studies the science of laughter. Sophie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. I hope you enjoyed myself. This episode was produced by Laura Correll, edited by Tara Boyle and Kimmela Vargas Restrepo.
而且真的很刻薄。真的非常非常不愉快。而我把这段经历变成了一场单口喜剧表演。……他们将笑到最后。非常感谢。苏菲·斯科特是伦敦大学学院的神经科学家，她在那里研究笑的科学。苏菲，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。我自己玩得很开心。本期节目由劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和金梅拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Kimmela Vargas Restrepo）剪辑。
Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu and Pathshah. Our unsung hero this week is my colleague Steven Thompson, who works at NPR Music. Steven sends out periodic notes announcing guests who are going to perform at the Tani Desk concert series at NPR and his notes are invariably filled with funny observations about his boss, his green Bay Packers football team, and sunsets. These emails, like the one about eating between 15 and 25 bowls of cereal one Friday night, do something we could all use more of in our lives. They make us laugh.
我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和帕思沙（Pathshah）。我们本周的无名英雄是我的同事史蒂芬·汤普森（Steven Thompson），他在NPR音乐部门工作。史蒂芬会定期发送邮件，宣布即将在NPR的小办公桌音乐会（Tiny Desk concert）系列中表演的嘉宾，他的邮件总是充满了对他的老板、他的绿湾包装工队橄榄球队以及日落的有趣观察。这些电子邮件，就像那封关于在一个周五晚上吃掉15到25碗麦片的邮件一样，做了一件我们生活中都希望能多看到一些的事。它们让我们开怀大笑。
You can hear Stephen for yourself on NPR's Pop Culture Happy Hour podcast. I'm Shankar Vita and them. See you next week. Because actually most people don't really like being tickled. I was doing a talk at the Raw Society a few years ago. This very elderly, very distinguished member of the Royal Society, fellow of the Royal Society went, I love to be tickles. LAUGHTER I am not going to tickle you, sir. That's not most people's reaction. Different show, different show, Sophie.
你可以在NPR的《流行文化快乐时光》（Pop Culture Happy Hour）播客中亲自听听史蒂芬的声音。我是香卡·维达姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们下周见。因为实际上大多数人其实并不喜欢被胳肢。几年前我在皇家学会做过一次演讲。皇家学会的一位非常年长、非常杰出的成员、皇家学会的院士说：“我喜欢被胳肢。”（笑声）我不会胳肢您的，先生。这可不是大多数人的反应。换个节目，换个节目，苏菲。
Different show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
换个节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。